I couldn't get it out my mind I had to
get hold of a psychologist
[Music]
can't go on
Jamie carragher is a Liverpool stalwart
730 odd appearances it's never going to
be another Jimmy character he's a winner
he will you know
it's just ridiculous I'm no huge Ronaldo
fan I think that's pretty obvious it's
sad for him the ways people are speaking
about Messi towards the end of his
career and Ronaldo and it's completely
different it's almost like he feels like
he's not racism I've got so much
admiration for him for his mental
strength to be able to withstand fresh
air criticism and I saw too many players
never recover from that I knew from the
first time I played football for me
winning was all that mattered if you say
to me what do I miss most of being a
professional footballer it's women
I'd rather cheat and win than not win
when Jaime loses a game is he different
that punish myself when I didn't perform
well and I regret that but absorbs that
thing of oh my God
I was just driving myself mad when I was
at my absolute Peak and best
that's when I needed more help the
feeling your stomach is that bad you
just you zombie there I always remember
and the only time I've ever did this in
my whole career
much of your success has been a result
of a winning mentality in some of the
toughest moments where does that come
from the reason why I've become the
player I have I think it's
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
[Music]
Jamie when I
start this podcast I usually start with
people's childhoods but as I was reading
through your story I think this is the
first time I'm going to start before the
person was even born
because I I read that
there was a possibility that you weren't
even going to be born because of a I
guess a misdiagnosis that your mother
was giving about you
can you take me back to that story yeah
that was uh
would have been about let's say would it
be in about 1977 obviously 78 I was born
and I mean mum has had two miscarriages
before me
and then
when I it will she feel pregnant with me
did the doctors nurses didn't know what
was wrong with the new something was
wrong and initially they were saying
that we think your child has got Spina
bifter and I think
well I'm saying it in those days maybe I
don't know if it's the same now there's
a chance you could terminate the
pregnancy if the if the baby was
whatever in order
and my mom was I think was given that
option and she my mom's my mom's very
holy things the right way that probably
at that stage in the early 20s she would
be going to church every day
she still goes every Sunday now
so here thing was not with the way she
says to me was
if our Lord wants me to have
a baby who's got Spina bifter or maybe
something else that's that's what's
being decided for me that's fine it's my
child I love that child
and
what I find
fascinating when you think of sort of
today
is that
the closer it got to the me being born
it wasn't Spina bifter but they still
knew something wasn't right
and it wasn't until
I was born that I had basically my
insides were on the outside
so I've I've uh gastro's gastroskitas
it's called the condition now I've got a
big scar right across my stomach I mean
if if someone has that condition today
and plenty of babies do it's a really
small scar
but the the thing that I think is
fascinating or just makes me think wow
on my mum's side is the fact that as
soon as I was born I was rushed away
straight away to Alder hay children's
hospital hospital which is still going
strong today in Liverpool and because of
what I've gone to achieve I've got a
real link with the hospital
and
uh through our charity we actually
funded the uh the ward that looks after
babies who have oh really what I had uh
but
I get pushed away
to children's hospital and I mean mum
doesn't know anything
there's no phones there's no she's still
in the Zachary Hospital
obviously I've got a problem straight up
to older hey my dad go straight there
but again there's no the technology
isn't like that and I just think how
long it must have been before one we mum
knew I was all right what I had how
could it have to go you know you aren't
quite fathom that when you think about
today and how quickly even get in touch
with with different people so uh I just
think about what was going through my
mum's behind there for that sort of the
next hour or two until you know she
probably found out everything was okay
your knowledge of that story and that
experience has that
left a lasting impact or impression on
you in terms of the decision your mum
made your mum made or being whisked away
or the operation or having this guy or
anything like that has that left any
sort of impression on you at all
yes
all about me more I would say you know
to to
have had two miscarriages to have that
going through your third pregnancy to
think you could lose the baby the no one
can quite give you a definitive answer
about what's going on with you know this
child in your stomach and then to
to not know straight away I just I just
I only know of now and when people have
kids and I've had my own kids and
everything's so documented isn't it
whether it's you know the first picture
on Instagram you're there with the the
baby when the baby's born
I I wasn't actually maybe we can get to
that later I wasn't there for my uh
firstborn
and that's something I do regret but I
just think about how
my mom must have felt and and sort of me
look at my mom because I've been very
lucky the life I know leads the
experience about I've I've had
you know it's it's not there if anyone
doesn't make you know saying he says no
longer with me dad of course but yeah
for me want to sort of make that
decision and uh I'm still here today
what about your dad what what um talk to
me about him and his character and what
impact that had on you before the age of
10.
it's a real big character yeah he's you
know he's
he'll be in the pope he'll have a debate
he'll get up and sing he'll he'll have
an argument with someone he's like a
real Larger than Life sort of character
who did you care about impressing the
most just not even in the context of
your parents but just who were you
trying to impress when you were young
because for me you know it might have
been my older brothers it could have
been my dad it could have been you know
a teacher who are you trying to impress
I mean the obvious wants to save me that
because he was the one who was always
there in terms of he talked about
football or like yeah
I mean mum never watched him play
football okay
I mean memo must have watched me play
five times in my life and that's nothing
to do with not being proud of me or not
being able I know it's not the done
thing now but it was always the case of
my dad took us the football and stayed
at all you know and and did what we
associate with women things and now
obviously
that type of comment or then thought
certainly back then be classed as like
sexist now and rightly so but that was
just the way it was it wasn't I don't
think my mum was
sort of badgered me dad to go to the
football she always just felt well okay
that's your thing to take them to the
football whether to be going to watch
everything as young kids or you know
play me games for
you know amateur teams little boys and I
want to start on that journey and when
you when he took you to football did he
have high standards and expectations
for you when you were playing
yes but I think that came not because he
was so desperate for me to be a
footballer I think that became because I
think he knew pretty early on
I had something
you know my dad had played football he's
had a
watched football my dad was a massive
football fan so he he done everything he
could do in football in terms of played
amateur football
managed amateur teams went to what you
have it at home and away so he was just
he was obsessed with football
so from a young age I think he was quite
tough for me a couple of times I'd Stand
Out only because he knew the standards I
could get to I'm one of those times is
like a story I put in my book
and I think sometimes with me Dad
listens back I think he
I think he doesn't like me to say the
story because I think he looks back at
it and thinks oh I wish I hadn't done
that but I've got no problem with it you
know I think it's part of my life past
my story that basically I was seven
years of age
and I didn't want to play in a game it
was that cold it was freezing it was
Hailstone and I got tackled and I
pretended that was a hair crying and
come off buddy me Dad and I'm the same
we we couldn't suffer bluffers or
phonies we'd say you know that's
hypothetic and he knew I was putting it
on
unless you say it was the last time I
did
and I read that part in your Memoir yeah
in your Memoir it says there was some
reigning football boots when you got
home yeah maybe there's a little bit of
artistic license there with the uh the
guy who wrote it but
no I think it was that and I think
throughout my football career
not much I'm talking about the big thing
for me and the big thing for me that I
want to pass on to my son
is having character
after me will will
take you to places that you don't think
are possible if you've got that
personality mental strength
character I think that overrides a lot
of things that's really why I'm asking
these questions because I could see
throughout your career that much of your
success has been a result of a winning
mentality and character in some of the
toughest moments and that's not the case
with all the footballers that I've
spoken to that's just the case with some
of them even when I sat with Peter
Crouch she referenced you as being
um so set on winning and so obsessed
with winning that you didn't even that
he didn't think you were ever enjoying
it and so I'm trying to figure out and
you smile when I say that because you
you know it's true I've read you I've
heard you say that subsequently but um
where where does that come from where
does that character and that obsession
with victory at all costs to the point
that you cause suffering in yourself
where does that come from
foreign
something like that maybe you know you
speak to a lot of probably
more people who give you that handset
than I do and maybe have a better
insight into it to me in some ways now
I'm not quite sure
but I knew from the first time I played
football
for me winning was all that mattered and
if you say to me what do I miss most of
being a professional footballer it's
winning
it's not the taken past not the training
a lot of people always say this I
footballers say this all the time I miss
the dressing room I don't miss the
dressing room
I missed the dressing room after the
game and we win that life you've done
something together
and I listened to crouchie's podcast
because I've seen it pop up somewhere I
think it was made online or some piece
of crowd said Stephen Gerard and Jamie
carragher race off players after 15 I
thought I better listen to this one uh
but
what Peter Crouch said Is Right
and he's probably looking at me a little
bit dumbfounds I can't understand that
but I can't understand him
for me Bill shankly said football is a
matter of life and death and
I don't think he meant that I think that
was obviously tongue and cheek at the
time and no football club knows that
statement
is not true more than Liverpool Football
Club
but it's very close to being true
that's the way I see it that's football
for me
is a way of life and and winning is all
that matters and for me when I played
I'd rather cheat and win
than not win and uh I don't ever be any
different
and that's why I think football is
taking me to places in my life
that almost means a tear to me I but
it's always taking me to places where
I'm like I don't feel like I'm ever
gonna get over it
you know results or something hasn't
gone well
you mentioned that that post-match
feeling is is the best and potentially
the feeling you missed but I've also
heard you describe it as relief you know
and that's um that's an interesting
thing because people would think the
post-match victory feeling would be
Euphoria and Elation but for you to
describe it as relief is a
curious word
because I knew how bad I'd feel if we
didn't win or they hadn't gone well it
was almost relief that I'm not going to
feel like that
for the next two or three days because I
would I think I punished myself a little
bit when I didn't perform well or we
didn't win
and I regret that but I don't know if I
could have done anything different
it was what it was me you know what I
spoke to a site at one stage I spoke to
I had to I had to
I wasn't asked to I had to get hold of a
psychologist sport psychologist that
were new because
what I was doing to myself was
I was just driving myself mad really
with the standards I was expecting of
myself and this I must say was not when
I was not playing well in shorter
conference this one was when I was at my
absolute Peak and best
that's when I needed more help
because I got to a stage where I felt I
couldn't make a mistake
if I if if I didn't play well I thought
we're gonna lose
yeah because I wasn't Daft I was playing
at my best I was a huge part of the team
and there's lots of other great players
around there of course but I knew I was
a huge influence in the Rafa beneath his
area era
and I felt I'd go into big games
thinking if I don't play well today I'm
not going to win
and
if I made a mistake and I always
remember the mistake I made it was aware
that Atletico Madrid
Champions League group game will win a
one nil but under pressure constantly
and I'm I'm playing really well I'm in
control
that was me and my elements away from
home in Europe
for Liverpool trying to get that clean
she's organized and talking to everyone
and a longboard and he scored
and in the airport on the way home
she's like this can't go on
uh this has got to stop you know that
what I'm actually doing to myself I've
played great I've made a little mistake
you know they've capitalized on it
but you can put yourself through that
what was the symptoms that you were
confronting in that moment why what
couldn't carry on so you had made that
mistake you're in the airport you're on
the plane whatever
what is the what's happening I couldn't
get it out my mind I couldn't I got like
shoot two nights when I was sleeping
I mean you want to say not to sleep and
I get a couple of hours I'll be like
constantly on my mind and wake up it was
the first thing to think about
and I was just like
what am I doing to myself but how would
you stop it but but the fascinating
thing was
when I spoke to the sports psychologist
that guy called Bill Bez we kind of knew
him from
the England squad
speaking to it and then it got to the
stage where I spoke to him probably two
or three times a season
almost like I reflect and you know
what's gone on
I couldn't change we actually got to the
bottom of actually this is what Tamika
knew who you are
this is the drive to sort of if you if
you did probably dismiss mistakes or
were not too bothered I'll be I'll be
fine next week
that wouldn't make I wouldn't make you
who you are and
I could still never Shake It Off I could
I couldn't but I almost by speaking to
him it made me understand and accept
that's what it was so I still went
through turmoil if I didn't play well
if I made a mistake I always wonder if
that was
like a byproduct of being a local player
I always think what would I have been
like about a plate for Aston Villa or
Tottenham you know I I didn't know that
many people you know I felt like you
were playing for
the club of the supporters of your
family and friends really if you know
did you ever feel anxiety in those
moments the feeling of anxiety so when
something is plaguing you so much that
you almost feel that kind of sense of
nervous energy that keeps you up at
night and you feel it in your stomach no
it was never anxiety I would say anger
and I want to put this rice it's like
I didn't even want to sleep when I get
to train in the next day did that come
out in your home life because it's hard
not to take that home with you yeah I
think it will have time
yeah
yeah 100 percent
I remember something came up
a year or two ago
on here on Twitter about
a group of players or a certain player
or maybe being a manager went out
another meal
or a few drinks after they'd lost
and with this big debate on uh on
Twitter well why shouldn't you know some
fannular fans are like he shouldn't be
like they shouldn't go out and there was
this few big debates and I think Gary
lineke mentioned something that I've
never not
chain I've never changed my plans on the
back of the results
okay that that sounds nice I thought it
was unbelievable I would change plans
every single week if that game didn't go
well
so that's where it was affected my home
life so in terms of organizing a night
owls going for a meal with friends
whatever it may be
I couldn't I couldn't show my face if
we'd have lost and I played poorly not a
chance and I couldn't believe that some
players
could could just carry on with the life
I'd be a bit like oh no you no you
because the feeling your stomach is that
bad you just you don't even want to be
he's gonna be there he's gonna be
whipped people you don't speak you know
that's that's what animal she got me and
I go back to that you know would it have
been different at another club I would
never wanted to play for another club
but that is the one thing I do think
about would it have resulted some
performances affected me differently
you come home after a you know
losing a game or something
you've got your family there your kids
run up hey
I mean to be fair me kids were quite
Young when I was still playing
but there was one game that stands out
when I couldn't get out of something I
was opening a restaurant I opened a
restaurant about 10 or 15 years ago
called Cathy Sports England
in Liverpool
and the two times we opened
those two games I didn't play well
and in my head before the game I'm
thinking I've got to play well in this
game because people will think of it
don't play well I've got my mind
somewhere else and I was probably too
focused on the game in some ways and
then I had to go and almost open the
restaurants and there was people here
I remember the second one it was like no
I went I was there 20 minutes I was like
I've got to go if I spoke to Nicola
which I might have done but I won't tell
you before this I asked the question and
I said when Jamie loses the game is he
different and what's he like what would
she have said to me
hundred percent yeah
100 what you said you reckon
he's not there
when I'm talking to him I think she'd
probably say that
maybe now at different times but I would
be I'll be in a chance
I'd just be sort of Daydream is people
will be speaking to me
and
it's probably best just to leave me
alone and not
try and get my mind off because
I couldn't
even if I if it did get my mind off I
know I'd go back to it
and you're talking about going home
I always remember one time when I said I
was in a trance where I was with the
players so I always remember
we were playing a game against Evan
which for me is the biggest game
I had a nightmare
in the game and we were going for a meal
afterwards with the team like an
official not a sort of few drinks it was
it was to to refuel basically this game
is an early morning kickoff we had a
Champions League game on the Tuesday
night in in Eindhoven
foreign
and we've gone to the center of
Liverpool for a meal just to make sure
eating the right food
and I remember just staring
just couldn't stop I was just I wasn't
even eating just just staring
and next I get a text message
Stevie Jared
it's just like he's there
he's gone don't worry about it it's gone
finished forget about you know just
you've got the time but I was just I
he could just see everyone was
devastated
but for me I just no I'm not trying to
make out that I cared more than anybody
else because everyone's got their own
ways of dealing with things but
I
yeah it was a yeah it was
it's a huge part of my life football it
always has been always will be I think
I'll always be affected by football
results
when I went that's when I was playing as
an Everton fan as a Liverpool fan right
now
football results will affect me it
sounds painful sounds like suffering
doesn't sound like well when you win I
can assure you I make sure I I I enjoy
them I know afterwards I said before
that it was relief but you had that
moment of sort of Joy the reason it was
difficult to enjoy
and why I'm probably different to a
Peter Crouch or certain players who came
in as a I think they'd come in from
clubs where they played once a week and
if they played well it was like I don't
need somebody to that game I'm gonna be
off for two or three days but as we have
a game Tuesday
Champions League or a cup game
and they'll be ready to enjoy that right
bang we're back on it now it was almost
like you're just on this train and you
nothing's getting in the way nothing's
not Unstoppable I can assure you it
wasn't the whole Doom and Gloom I loved
it and so many nights and times and
experiences but I do wish I was a little
bit kinder to myself on the back of a
poor performance or a defeat I mean does
what I keep thinking about one standing
out
we we we won the FA Cup Final in 2006.
personally out of the great season we'd
we kept 33 clean sheets which was one
away from a record which was which was
obviously a lot
we played the Cup Final I scored their
own goal I didn't play well Stevie Jack
had wins the final and we go on the open
bus tour
around Liverpool so I've had a great
season but not had a great last game
and my son's on the bus with me and I go
on the top of the bus to start with
but you're on the bus for maybe three or
four hours
within an hour I was downstairs I just
sat there thinking oh
it didn't go well I didn't do that you
know I didn't do and I was thinking now
when I look I'm embarrassed I'm like
what are you doing it was one game
you've had an unbelievable season the
team have we won the FA Cup we finished
the season with a trophy
but I couldn't it was almost like I was
up there acting because I didn't feel
like celebrating but we won the cup
you know just because I hadn't I I'd
made a mistake hadn't played
particularly well
I know most players will be able to go
I've had a great season there's only one
game we won
I found it tough people that have that
Winner's mindset they um as you kind of
alluded to a second ago they often
struggled to understand those that don't
to relate to them and they often have a
lot of friction with the people that
don't have the Winner's mindset because
when you see the world and that way I
saw it a lot in um Michael Jordan's
documentary Last Dance brilliant wasn't
that yeah amazing I think I've got a
poster upstairs book after I watched it
but um he had that mindset where he was
you could see he would like pick on
certain people who who wouldn't meet him
at his level did you ever find yourself
and Stevie doing that where if someone
came into the dressing room and they and
they weren't at that level you would you
would either you'd force them out or
you'd I mean that's kind of what Peter
Crouch was alluding to right that he was
kind of saying that you two would be
protecting the bar yeah I mean
I think what what happens is I think
what Peter was trying to mention which I
think is a little bit unfair the way he
described it was that when a new player
came in
I think
me and Steve were fans we ain't just
players we were fans it was like oh God
I hope he's good you know like a fan was
out this new Fella's good and when
you're coming after the first training
session it'd be more than a joke oh God
this doesn't look good does it or you
know what I mean that type of thing
about God because I hope this goes well
uh but I was Stevie
Stevie was different to me and I was
very vocal very emotional
Stevie's maybe body language on the
picture times will be questioned if you
know he wasn't happy with somebody he
might turn away
you know whereas I'd be
remonstrating screaming shouting you
know and not in terms of someone hadn't
played Paul poorly but might have been
more in terms of organization someone
doing the job for the team where are you
where you need to be I always felt like
I was
the coach of the team in some ways and
because I played a center-back and I
could you know see the whole team in
front of me yeah but we would be on top
of people but I don't I wouldn't like
that to come across in like a a bullion
way or you're trying to you know keep
people down here we loved
because you wanted to win that was all
that matter it wasn't about securing
your place or making sure I was
protected in any way it was that thing
of like
it's Liverpool it
the big clubs
it's not enough to play Ford man I know
some people think I played for this club
and it's on your CV and it's a great
achievement to get to a Liverpool or
United Chelsea City
but it's not enough to play for and
you've got to win the whole existence of
those clubs about winning if they're not
winning there's no point
you know so that was my thing my drive
at Liverpool was to win every single day
when Jared Julia came in came in as a
managers Julia so Julia Gerard we'll
just call him Gerard Julia
um when he arrived at uh Liverpool in I
think it was 1986 1998 1998 he came into
the the club
um
the place took to him at faster than I
read because he one of the key decisions
he made was around Paul lince
you see the players talk to him yeah and
no I think he found it difficult to
start with really I think it was a a big
split in the camp
in that the players would come before
that with Roy Evans and Jared Huli came
in he was new to it
and
yeah I think it was tough for him enough
for this season
yeah did that turn at some point did he
win the trust of the players yeah I mean
yeah he put Paul in great
fella I get on great with paulins great
player as well
didn't have the career that Liverpool
he's had maybe at other clubs
and I think gerardi just wanted to make
a fresh start and he wanted to I think
most a lot of managers do it
the the take on
you know the uh the big guy if you like
and it was certainly that he was I think
he was maybe England's captain or Vice
Captain at the time
but he wanted a completely
revolutionized Liverpool and completely
changer and yeah he had a Wedgewood with
paulins and the thing was not about him
having weeds as such but also the fact
that he didn't sort of back down he
really held his own he had a strong
argument in the team meeting I think wow
we just stood up to probably one of the
best Midfield players of his generation
what was that strong argument in the
team meeting it was it was over
Poland's question what we're doing in
training as senior Pros do at times you
know we're trying to get it right why
are we doing this why are we doing that
and I think General and Julia saw this
has this opportunity to sort of stand
his authority it was almost like I would
imagine he was glad
paulins had said it and it was what it
was Poland's in some ways and I don't
think the message was for Pauline
because I think he was always going to
get rid of NC I think the message was
the rest of us
you know don't don't try and take me on
this is what we're going to do publicly
in front of in the team meeting yeah
told Paul yeah basically but not you
wouldn't be at this club anymore but he
questioned his desire in a game uh
Anthony fairpoints was probably one of
the bravest footballers you'd say but in
a particular game against Manchester
United
we'd lost it 2-1 and we'd lost two goals
in the last minute and I think it was a
very so defeat for everyone
so I think everyone was a little bit
emotional about it
and because he had jumped up and said
something he just went straight back and
said he wasn't happy that he'd come off
he shouldn't have come off my captain
should come off on a stretcher from Old
Trafford and it was it was interesting
with Jared Julia in that
we we had him the first foreign manager
and all of a sudden people would
associate him with this flee football
and being maybe a bit nice but that was
that was what the Liverpool team was
before General Juliet came he completely
went the other way and was once a big
strong powerful player's aggression and
that's why me and him are such a great
relationship because I was such a
competitor maybe he didn't have the
quality that some of the players had in
the Roy Evans team if you're liking some
of the football they played was
outstanding
but he just wanted people who would die
for that [ __ ] because I I read that part
of the reason why his reign as manager
sort of came to an end was because he
made some bad signings and he was
he didn't really inquire enough about
the players that he was signing's
character and their personality and so
and I was just so compelled by that idea
that that's one of the most important
things when you're building teams is
finding people that have the same like
mentality and character versus just
great sort of technical players I think
about the same in business like I'm
always considering how someone will
um support our culture make our culture
better raise the bar in terms of like
that mentality versus just being able to
do [ __ ] a thousand kick-ups or
whatever and loads of skills yeah I I
think you do need the same mentality to
play for Liverpool what does that mean
and the other big clubs
to be able to withstand pressure
criticism
that comes your way so often I saw a lot
of Liverpool players who would start
really well
and it wouldn't it wouldn't make me
think we've got a great player here I'd
always think
let's see a couple of months down the
line because I knew what was coming
because every player goes through a few
by games he gets criticism whatever it
may be and I saw too many players never
recover from that
and that that tells me now for me the
top level football is mentality it was
do you have that personality character
to get you through
those tough moments and come back and
fight back and not give in can you teach
that I don't know you tell me what do
you think
um I tend to believe that it comes from
ex experience I think resilience and
that sort of character those character
traits come from being knocked down
loads of time so when the tenth failure
or knockdown comes or the tenth moment
of hardship comes you're more equipped
to deal with it
um so players that haven't been through
the tougher you know challenges in their
life maybe in their personal life maybe
where they come from don't have that
well it's interesting we're doing this
uh this afternoon and this morning
someone in front of the operation
yes indeed yeah right so he's going for
the operation he's a professional
footballer
and
painfully haven't been able to probably
sleep about it thinking about it you
know just
want to do as much as you can you know
to help them because it's your son
but the thing I keep jumping home to him
and I keep saying it almost every day
we're not using this as an excuse
this is not going in the way
it's like this happened is it okay boom
we're going again it's like
this I know for a lot of people or
players or young players or whatever it
may be
would be a hero to come across and
understandably so
but it's not in years to come gonna be
oh I didn't quite do what I wanted
because of that knee up yeah and this
never happened and that it's like no
there's there's going to be lots of
things in his career
as in my career obstacles in the way
you've got to get over them you've got
to get them all the way or you've got to
deal with it and then keep going
nuttings and that was always my mindset
and that's what I'm trying to put into
my son I'm pretty confident he's got
that mindset of not the structure
nothing getting your way you don't use
anything as an excuse or a reason why
something didn't happen that no excuse
mentality just you keep going nothing
gets not no obstacles in the way
you said earlier on that you might not
have cared as much as you did you might
not have had that that same level of um
sort of excruciating Obsession and and
care about the results and the outcome
and winning if you'd been at another
club and you were at another club which
is England and you didn't seem to care
as much you said that you remember I I
was quite shocked to read that that
remember the text message that said [ __ ]
it it's only England and
um generally you didn't seem to be as
excruciatingly hard on yourself after
losing for England
as you did with losing for Liverpool
I think that was down to the fact that I
didn't carry the same responsibility
because I I never really played I was
like a squad player really I wouldn't
Clash myself as patriotic
not at all
can you be patriotic if you're on city
is that is that a word or is there
something I have no idea
I'm actually massively passionate about
my own city
um
maybe that comes from the way we're
brought up in Liverpool
you know the
thing of you feel as if like a lot of
the country's against you and maybe
that's
some of it's true some people outside
other people think oh that's a chip on
your shoulder but there is that so we
sort of buy into that and that doesn't
mean like
I'm against England as such
but it watching England now in the World
Cup would never take me to a place
emotionally
the way it would if I saw a Liverpool
playing it just wouldn't take me there
it's not like a conscious thing of ugh
I'm not gonna make I'm not gonna be
happy about this it's just
inside me and and that wasn't just when
I was playing for him that was when I
was a
child I'd be thinking why in England
because they haven't players you know we
almost felt like England was a team from
down south or a London team that's just
the feeling I had and but I think if if
I would have become a Mainstay of the
England team
I think I would have felt that I think I
would have got there and that's me one
disappointment in my football great it's
the only team in my life from when I
started five years ago I didn't dominate
I'm gonna say dominate was
be a Mainstay of the team be one of the
voices of the team be one of the leaders
because I wasn't good enough
that's a simple fact there's lots of
plays that you've encountered in your
career that didn't reach their potential
you're talking about Reaching Your
Potential doing your best getting to the
getting to the top of your potential a
second ago when you think about why
those players didn't reach their
potential if you had to point out
characteristics or behaviors that led
them to miss their potential what would
those behaviors be
the traits of losers hmm
I think blaming other people at
different times for their own
poor games mistakes
always looking for excuses I would say
I think I'm I'm pretty honest and I was
as a player and I always remember
when I was a young lady I had a bad game
I keep talking about games
you remember them more yeah but a very
famous coach it was a huge inspiration
to me was running around
and uh I played a game and played poorly
and I did the ninja after the game
saying it was my fault those goals were
my fault
you know this was the
a coach who was a a real sort of man's
man a legend of Liverpool Football Club
he wasn't the coach then he still used
to come in and walk around the training
ground
and he said don't have to do that again
he said you don't need to
open yourself up like that he should be
honest with an injection room and see a
manager but he said you know what I mean
somebody's got to be clever and look
after yourself a little bit and you
don't need to
be as honest you think you're doing the
right thing and I think
I knew exactly where he was coming from
I think at times you need to be honest
but I think it was probably a lot of the
times like that you maybe need to
protect yourself a little bit but you're
never hide behind the fact that it was
someone else's fault and again I keep
going back to me soon because I'm not a
coach or a manager and people say to me
you know could you give something back
but I was trying to give it back to me
soon and things like that don't question
them aren't you don't make excuses don't
blame the manager or if you come in and
say oh the culture the trainer well get
shot out of it don't don't be in the
direction I'm saying oh this isn't good
or that isn't good
quick one from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better as some of you may know
by now Blue Jeans by Verizon offers
seamless high quality video conferencing
but the reason why I use blue jeans
versus other video conferencing tools is
because of immersion their tools make
you feel more connected to the employees
or customers you're trying to engage
with and now they're launching one of
their biggest feature enhancements to
impact virtual events so far called Blue
Jean Studio actually used it the other
day I did a virtual event using the
studio which I think about 700 of you
came to TV level production quality all
done by one person with very little
technical experience on a laptop so if
you've got an event coming up and you're
thinking about doing it virtually check
out blue jean studio now let me know
what you think because I genuinely
believe I know this is an advert and I'm
supposed to say this but I genuinely
believe it's the best tool I've seen for
doing really immersive simple but high
quality production virtual events
quick one from our longest standing
sponsor hero I I can't tell you over the
last I'd say over the last really it's
been about two and a half years it was
really um post pandemic how much my
health has become such a huge priority
in my life and I have this laser laser
focused on what I'm putting into my body
it's funny because as you get older you
can start to feel the things you're
putting into your body more and more and
more
um and if I if I put something into my
body especially things like gluten if I
put those things in my body I feel them
tremendously the next day my energy
levels my sleep and everything in
between huel has been probably the most
important partner in my health Journey
because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and I trust it most of my
team that are in this room with me
consume it and get the benefits of it
too so if you haven't already tried your
do so
on the point of questioning the manager
one of the things I read was that Gerald
Julia Julia cuts his bloody name Julia
Julia cool one of the reasons why he
ultimately ended up leaving the club
um was because he started to lose his
authority in the dressing room now Peter
Crouch said to me that
great managers even when they don't know
the right answers pretend they do
because they know that if they ever get
to a point where the players know that
they're not in control then the
Authority's gone and there was a story I
read about Gerard wholey a
um
picking a team and then going and asking
Jared if it was the correct team
and then Gerard said it's not the
correct team and changed it
this happened in
in spring in 2004 in in the run-up to a
Premier League match way to Manchester
United
Jared Julio picked the team but then
consulted with Gerard whether the
selection was right who said it wasn't
right and then Julia changed it
I don't I don't it rings a bell I don't
know the specific game if that was the
right game but I think towards the end
of his time
I think the results are going well and
marriages no matter who they are they
will lose confidence and Stevie at that
time was obviously a mega stat and
you're trying to maybe keep people on
side if you're like not that I think the
players were ever offside with with
Gerard Julia but that confidence and
belief in the manager starts to have
away when results don't go well I
wouldn't say Gerard Healy ever lost
digestion in terms of how we felt about
him
as a man but it was it was a time for
her to come to an end there's no doubt
about that and it's an interesting one
that does a manager lose the dressing
room
yes
he's always lost part of adjustment
because the players who he's not picking
but I think it's when that belief goes
really but for me
again I think I was different to all the
players because I never played for the
manager
ever
I always play for the club and again
because it was the club I always felt
like I played for the club and the
supporters and I'm not saying that too
Curry favor with the supporters as such
but
no manager bought me
you know I I didn't no one managing
anything as such I mean bro you haven't
given me me Debbie or supposing
but the managers played me but I never
had that sort of feeling that
we need to win this for the manager
Rafa Benitez comes in next what's the
difference between Gerard Julia and Rafa
Benitez in terms of style because I find
it so compelling that managers can be
great for various different reasons and
we think of management as like a formula
but as I sit here with football players
that I've had seven eight nine managers
they all say that managers are
completely different in their stolen
approach
yeah raffle was completely different
Jared Julia was a manager
I think Gerard wholey was the type of
guy who could
he could manage an organization didn't
just have to be football I think he
could have been a bank manager he could
have
been a CEO if you're like he organized
people get everyone focused on you know
what do we want to achieve and but the
actual day-to-day stuff of coaching I
thought it wasn't as Forte and I'd sound
strange I don't think he had a huge
knowledge of the game enough but it
wasn't somebody was going to say
something something to you in a coaching
session or a tactical point that made
you think oh I never did that before or
that's a bit different it wasn't like
that his thing was bringing people
together for a common goal and almost
what I've described them to other people
people say
Clive Woodward the the England rugby
College World Cup winning culture was
probably similar in that now he's had
all the cultures but he's always been
coming up with ideas to create sort of a
Siege mentality or togetherness whereas
Rapha was a coach he was on that
training pitch every day
and he was a lot colder than Gerard
Julia he was a lot more interested in
the kids the wife you know yourself you
know we speak ask me about my dad or
different things like that was Jared who
Rafa didn't want to get involved in
anything it was just football I mean if
the guy was obsessed with football Raffa
was just like he was probably above me
somewhere but it was different but it
doesn't
I I mean I'll be honest with you when we
describe managers
like the one who come a couple after was
Roy Hodgson and it didn't go
particularly well but we point it
when a new manager comes in
I want to get whatever I can from
so it may not work for Liverpool I may
not like
X but I might like lion's head I'm sorry
so
you're always going to be a sponge and
taking things in and learning things and
I think when John Julia came in I was a
bit Power Player
and then became a fully fledged member
of Liverpool's first 11 for the next
five years and then Rafa came in
and then we again stepped up a level to
become the Vice Captain and one of the
leaders in the team one of the best
players in the team
so I always think I got the most
from these these other managers coming
in you know certainly I don't think he
would have ever heard of me
maybe you know not too much but I think
it's important when people come into
your life figures of authority
you've got to basically squeeze
everything out of them to your advantage
and I think I did that with both
managers
let's do the biggest prone con then so
from what I of these individuals as
managers so Jared Julia you said he's a
great sort of man manager CEO type
that's probably from what I hear one of
his greatest strengths his downside is
maybe a lack of football knowledge is
that what you're I wouldn't say it was a
downside because he had cultures around
him
who who did the training sessions it
just it got to its its natural end right
in that
you know we shouldn't forget him and he
nearly lost his life managing Liverpool
and he's then making decisions is he
in a fully you know football focused
state of mind but he's actually
recovering from almost losing his life
and we made a few signings that didn't
work and and to be honest that's always
How It Ends for Liverpool managers when
it comes to the end that they have a
summer where they buy a few plays they
don't quite work out and then the next
manager has to has to come in because
you know the the energy and the
excitement not just from the squad but
also the supporters just peed at an
house so rapha's great tactically
obsessed with football obsessed with the
game but his sort of downside was if
there I mean everyone has a [ __ ]
downside I have a downside as a manager
yeah yeah is is probably the the man
management stuff you yeah but I don't
think that's that stops US winning as
such yes nobody is everything yeah Alex
Ferguson is not a cult she's bought but
we more like a Gerard wholey type figure
and there's cultures there Rafa Benitez
people question his man management but I
I don't question the research and I
don't question Gerard who like oh the
managers you've just got to do what's
your strength that's your strength or
what if Rafa benite says his strength is
not the man management I'm putting this
act on it's all about being obsessed
with football and coaching every single
day do what you're good at and it is not
interesting is there's so many ways to
win because when I sort of sat here with
all the United players Rio Patrice Gary
they all say about Sir Alex Ferguson
they go manager but only came in the
training room dressing around twice in
26 years whatever and I and then you
hear about these other people like Rafa
who also tremendously successful
um won the biggest trophies you could
possibly win but wasn't that way
inclined history is written by the
winner it doesn't matter what you do so
if Sir Alex Ferguson doesn't do well at
Man United
those same plays be sent to you he's not
at the training ground yeah he's never
there yeah we don't do tactical work he
doesn't do any culture it it's all about
women
and and to be honest what you're saying
that is interesting because one time I
remember Rafa Benitez
he knew someone at United and he said
physician doesn't even coach because in
rapha's mind you've got to be
to be a top man you're a coach you know
I think when him and Mourinho came along
they were like cultures I probably
couldn't get their heads around the way
Alex Ferguson was and it was almost
it was almost a little bit dismissive
and it wasn't like I was trying to
defend the Manchester United manager it
was just a training if infection doesn't
even do the coaching I said so what yeah
it's like it doesn't matter he wins
there's different ways of winning and
that's my thing on TV now there's no
right or wrong way to play football it's
being the best you can be at what you do
and that and if that's for Rapides is
being on that training now coaching not
getting involved in stuff away from the
pitch well that's someone else's job
you know no one is perfect at any Alex
Ferguson wasn't a great coach so he
brought in great coaches I think that's
really important not just in in
in football management I actually think
in life in that for me I'm a little bit
weary of getting involved in things but
I think that's not my area of expertise
I think I'd be a little better arrogance
of Michelle to think I could just
parachute myself in there and
you know start running the show or you
get right involved in it so I think we
all got to know what our students are
and all God are no way we need help
because we all need help that's what
Richard Branson taught me
um you know reading through his story
but also getting to speak to him on this
podcast this is a guy who didn't know
what the difference between net profit
and gross profit until I think he was 50
which is the one of the key principles
like understandings of running a
business
dyslexic can't look at presentations if
you try and show him words on a slide
deck he'll he won't look at it he'll
only look at pictures he's got so many
deficiencies in areas that you think are
critical to business but
the one thing that everyone says he says
and everyone around him says was because
of all of his deficiencies he made up
for it by being the best delegator in
the world so he found people that could
plug all of these gaps and gave them
huge responsibility and you think you
know by the age of
at the same time when he doesn't know
the difference between net profit and
gross profit he's running 50 different
companies virgin is now 400 different
companies and you go how is someone
who's in his own words like not good at
business
doing that well just a supreme delegator
and Sir Alex focused in the same bad
coach but had can't remember his name
that guy that did it Carlos Keys lots of
different ones didn't he but I think I
think what you're saying
is really good because
the Creator I've had has afforded me so
many opportunities I'm so fortunate that
I I mean I'm speaking to you you know
you're speaking to other people who are
experts in their field
but when you speak to them and that
story about Richard Branson
is perfect in that
if you don't know them and you know say
my family and friends sometimes they're
fascinated by some of the people I meet
and I said I'm lucky to be in certain
situations and
they look at these people like that
they're extraordinary and when you've
got a sort of relationship with someone
whether it's someone I work on TV with
they're just normal people and they've
got the same sort of insecurities that
you've got but they've got something
about them where they've got sort of
maybe it's an opportunity that's a
reason they've grabbed it with both
hands they've an enthusiasm something
about them
put them in that position but do not
Extraordinary People they've got an
extraordinary talent for that you know
which finds themselves I feel it in that
field so
that thing where people are so impressed
with someone or think they're going to
give them these words that they've never
heard of before
I think the olds that are getting now I
realize that a lot of people in you know
great positions it's not because they're
some genius sometimes as I said it's
opportunity they've seen a niche in the
market whatever it may be they've just
gone out there and grabbed it you know
there's a real trap I've noticed based
on exactly what you've said where
someone's successful so what we do is we
assume that they get everything right
and so with Richard Branson because he's
a super successful entrepreneur we
assume that he's the best at marketing
branding Finance all of these things and
I noticed this a lot when I was in San
Francisco and we were it was when
Snapchat the app had blown up and we
were building a chat app and what you'd
see the team doing was whenever we were
trying to make a decision we the team
were going well what does Snapchat do
because Snapchat was successful we
assumed that their marketing strategy
every feature they had everything they
did with the login form we assumed
everything they did was right
um and I came to I came to sort of see
that bias in myself and it's exactly
what you've described if we see someone
who is at the top of the game
we assume that they are Godlike in
everything that's what you do with
Richard Branson she means the best
speaker in the world you've seen the
best salesman who know in reality from
what I've learned from doing this and
honestly looking at my own life because
I'm not actually good at business like
I'm not good at the business stuff I'm
not good at like Finance
um operations processes but I'm good at
this one thing and that's what I learned
from Richard is Richard's good at this
one thing he's like good I'd say he's
good at The Branding piece but he's just
an unbelievable delegator
um so that's yeah I mean that's that's
what I got from all of that but it's
it's funny having this conversation in
the wake of Richard Branson because he's
the the best example of that one of the
obviously one of the defining moments uh
I think in football generally not just
as live as a Liverpool player or a
Liverpool fan was that final away at
Istanbul
you uh you go in at half time I think
it's 2005 final you go in three nil down
when you go down that tunnel at three
nil down
honestly do you think you can turn that
game around no no no
not at all no what are you thinking when
you walk through the tunnel then there's
gonna be six nil is that what you're
thinking oh how can we stop it being six
nil
I think if you lose again three nil
it happens
if you lose five or six and it's
remembered
and that was my fear that was fear what
happened in the dressing room what did
Rafa say
not a lot
he wasn't a motivator he was he was a
tactician
and he made changes in this system-wise
strategically to change it but if I'm
being honest I think he changed the
changes he made was not to win the game
I think the changes he made was to stop
it becoming five or six nil
because we actually brought on a
defensive Midfield player Didier man we
went to
you can call it three at the back but
you can you can be B5 at the back if you
like rather than playing four
don't get me wrong the changes helped us
go on and get the goals but I think
initially we need to stop what AC Milano
doing otherwise this is going to be a
massacre why did the game turn around
I think the change is Rafa made
a little bit of luck
and Steven Gerard
hmm he scores the head oh 54 minutes or
something and then within a couple of
more minutes you've you're three now
three three but that's that's the little
bit of looking you just go so quickly
right after that that happens in some
games and
we did get a little bit of a look uh I
think the Lions would actually flagged
for an offside the referee didn't see it
and they carried on playing for 30
seconds so the lantern puts his flag
down
and that's in the run-up two was getting
our second goal
so we scored the second goal and then
generation it's just you know when
you're on a football pitch you smell it
it's 3-2
we knew it was good I knew it was gonna
be three three everybody knew it was
going to be three three just what is
that I don't know
you just the the
reason I know is because when we score
3-2
no one celebrated the goal scorer
everyone just runs back
he started celebrating he starts
celebrating but it's
he was going crazy I remember thinking
you shouldn't do that yeah but
everyone's back it's like everyone's
saying oof in his own and you don't need
to speak to other people
sometimes there's moments in games it
just you can smell it you can feel
something's happening is that a culture
thing as well because there's certain
clubs you have that when when they go
two-nil down three nil down no everyone
goes oh they're gonna do it they're
gonna come back and there's that
mentality where you go yeah we're not
safe here they're coming for us
I think Liverpool man united have got it
City you seem to have it now a city yeah
certainly in the last couple of years on
the Pep Guardiola
I've always felt Chelsea have had that
in the last 10 years or so even when
they went at the best they'd still find
a way to win
and yeah I know our club's got that and
we'll always have that you just it just
you feel like something's gonna happen
why why is Liverpool done so well in the
Champions League
I think a lot of that is emotion
belief getting winning those finals as
well yeah winning finals the history
that's gone before the anfield crowd
believe that the opposition coming to
anfield believe that something's going
to happen special this is a this is a
mythical football ground do you believe
they're the best fans in the Premier
League
I I wouldn't say that and the reason I
wouldn't say that because everybody
thinks they're the best fans yeah and I
think if I do say that
I won't be turning on my Twitter
notifications in a few days after this
podcast comes out but but no
um
I would say yes I
but every set of supporters what they do
to follow their team home and away I
think I'm feel special I don't think
anyone could deny that that there's
something special
Adam feel that doesn't happen at any
other places where
I think when we say that you know the
crowd suck the goal in well the
opposition manager would always say
before the game
no Spectators ever scored a goal
that's pretty obvious
but Adam field it almost feels like I
think even top managers even Pep
Guardiola he's his record that anfield
maybe the greatest manager of all time
he's had some of the greatest teams of
all time his record and I'm feels
horrendous and he
he hasn't changed his mind when he goes
to anfield it's just like the
environment the atmosphere just he
mad things happen at HomeField was that
the Pinnacle of your career that that
final battle oh yeah Istanbul
I have to be honest
I couldn't believe I was playing at that
level
well
I was a huge football fan
probably the biggest football fan in the
dressing room who was just obsessed with
football red watched everything
and I know about all the great teams you
know going back to the Real Madrid teams
of the 50s the Stefan postcas
um then you probably got to buy a Munich
teams of Beckham Bauer Krave teams just
before that
uh Total Football Holland then you've
got the AC Milan team the great teams
who dominate European football AC Milan
late 80s early 90s I could name all the
players
what they did guardiola's team of
Barcelona obviously that was after we
were involved in the Champions League
and
I'm very honest about
my capabilities of footballer
but I didn't think I was that level
some people may still think I'm not
that's obviously football's opinions but
I always remember when we won the
semi-final against Chelsea
I wasn't thinking right we're going to
win the championship meet me first few
days afterwards was I'm playing the
Champions League final you know this is
like Maldini berazi Crow you know all
these players who who I absolutely
idolize and know so much about the
defined by the European Cup
or a tournament I always think the
greatest players of all time
they've either dominated the European
couple they've won the World Cup of the
Euros or something it's winning leagues
is not enough to be really
put yourself on a level of the real
greats that's what they all do
and it was almost wow I can't believe
I'm I'm playing at this level you know
that made me think about Ronaldo
obviously he's he's out the World Cup
now and you've had a couple of strong
opinions on Ronaldo over the last couple
of weeks have I to be honest following
the interview he did and then I'm a man
united fan so I I didn't take it
especially well what he said and how he
did it and I thought it was very
self-serving and looked selfish Etc
um but there's probably another way to
do it and I wonder now I actually wonder
if he regrets doing it I regret I wonder
if he he knew it would play out like it
did and then he'd go to the World Cup be
benched again which almost kind of
validates Eric tenhag's position but
what's your whole stance on the Ronaldo
Saga
I actually only watched the full
interview a couple of days ago he did
with Piers Morgan I'd only seen clips of
it
and I watched the full interview
I'm not sure he's a guy who regrets
anything or too much if I'm being
totally honest or simply doesn't give
off that maybe in his private thoughts
I think the Poetry one will have hated
him but you know it's
he's fallible you know he's he's not
superhuman he's he's one of the greatest
players of all time he's special but I
I mean I'm no huge Ronaldo fan I think
that's pretty obvious and that's not for
his football and ability I actually I
got so much admiration for him for his
mental strength I just think it's
unbelievable
I think probably one of the strongest
players mentally
because he
he's had that thing his whole career for
how good he is he still had such a messy
on his shoulder it's always he could
never almost sit back and go
I'm the best almost relax he's always
had this constant yeah be not as good as
Messi and I know people it splits people
but I would say the majority of people
would probably side with Messi out I
would I would imagine I think that they
do
and I think to always have that and
always have that thing of trying to
prove people wrong and I've got that on
a completely different level
it's almost like he feels like he's not
rated even though everyone says he's one
of the best players of all time and I
and I can't help but admire that drive
because
I've got that drive but just not that
ability that he's got
but I just I mean I'm saying I don't
want him to sort of ruin his legacy with
interviews I mean I don't really care
it's not not my problem but
it's it's it's sad for him
the way people people are speaking about
messy towards the end of his career and
Ronaldo and it's completely different
and it's not to do with what's going on
in the pitch I think it's always that
idea that Ronaldo was about himself it
was the eagle whereas Messi has painted
this this like sync figure when I don't
actually think that's true
but people are talking about what messy
to win the World Cup you know with
Ronaldo it's like he's not the same
player but who is the same player to 37
so he's getting criticized for not being
the same player 37-38 when really he's
getting loads of that stage of his
career but because of the way he comes
across he storms off the pitch uh storms
down the tunnel he he's given that
interview people have obviously going on
Forum now and uh where does he go from
here because he because if he had had a
phenomenal World Cup then there'd
probably be a lot of doors open for him
some top sides would probably want him
even just for a year contract or
something but in the wake of being a
disruptive employer at his last role and
then going off to the euros and being
either a disruptive employee or just a
little poor performing employee he makes
you wonder like what manager is going to
want to take on that ego but also
without the upside you get with just
like incredible unfilled performance so
it's now just it seems like it's just
it's tilted the other way now yeah I
mean Ronaldo hasn't changed yeah he's
always been that sort of
character everyone's known that but he
was with the hassle yeah exactly now and
that's like everything in football you
know when we talk about a manager making
a decision
can you put up with that and it's not
it's in your business isn't it in your
life you know you don't cut off your
noses about your face but when I get to
that stage where you're thinking this
will become a more of a problem
and again I say that to be soon you know
when a manager looks at you as a player
every manager wants the same thing
performance low maintenance that's it
you know Satan players
you know and it's when it goes starts
getting weighted to the high maintenance
is basically the scales are more tilted
towards the high maintenance it's time
to go did you see any high maintenance
players in your career
that were specific particularly
troublesome
that weird or wind were
it's funny at Liverpool
in that
I think Liverpool's a unique Club
and I'm sure it's still the same
Liverpool supports have an obsession
with the manager that I don't think I've
seen at any other club
so when the team win it's about shankly
Paisley now it's klopp we know there's
great players
but the adulation I think starts with
Bill shankly
and when we when Liverpool win it's
about the manager and the players it's
not the players then the manager so the
managers are at Liverpool I think have
always had a great deal of authority
they've always had the people with them
so it's never a case of a players could
get a manager out and I never saw that
at Liverpool certainly not when I was
there Roy Hodgkin had a tough time at
Liverpool
he wasn't the right manager for the club
and the club moved around after about
six months why was he the right manager
he just he didn't get the club he didn't
say the right things in the Press
he was he was too defensive for
Liverpool for the top not just for
Liverpool but for any top club but
listen he'd had success in his career
playing that way and he wasn't going to
change when he was in the 60s so it was
just the wrong appointment it didn't
work I read that Gerard deliberately
missed a penalty to no that's not true
yeah I wonder I couldn't believe it was
true but I read that's what I read and I
thought there's no [ __ ] way that
Jared would miss a penalty I actually
went upstairs before you came and
watched it to see Gerald's body language
and Gerard did look pissed off
nothing like that and I mean I was I
felt sorry for him hey to be honest but
me points of making them what the club
is
I think it would always be difficult at
any stage
for a player to have this big ego to
sort of try and think he was more
powerful than manager because I think
that's why managers love being Manager
of Liverpool is because they'd always
get time you look at you can clap now
and there's a spell in in the season
the pandemic season where he's done he's
not amazing he's a Godlike figure
but other people actually lost six games
a whole against teams in the bottom of
the table in a row
and I'm not saying you should have been
exactly what I'm saying this I know the
clubs that question would have been
asked
I don't even mean one Liverpool support
as a saying one yeah it would have
actually even contemplated that for
anything because that's the type of
support that they've been brought up on
the manager knows what he's doing well
one of my best friends is um I love my
maybe my best friend in the world is a
Liverpool fan and I I said to him this
year when Liverpool was struggling I
said what would it take for you to
become clop out he wouldn't answer the
question I pressed him I pressed him for
weeks and weeks and weeks eventually I
was like if Liverpool get relegated are
you still klopping he was like yeah and
he just like leaves the group chat but
it's like a religious phenomenon yeah I
just I don't even with Vegas in a menu I
know he was he was a mumbly unbelievable
but I just think when I go to see man
United's past a big rival it'll be
George best and Bobby Charlton in that
and then maybe you know Maples becomes
after them in some ways maybe I'm wrong
but it just feels like different at
Liverpool I think that gives managers
huge power and why I don't think I've
ever encountered what I would call
player power as such at Liverpool
probably why Liverpool have been
successful though because many other
clubs have struggled with that even
Manchester United most recently with
some of the big personalities we've had
where the manager doesn't have authority
and you just get you get into the first
season and you go the manager is going
to be fired because we're not going to
get rid of this world-class player
um and then you I was speaking to Jesse
lingard about this like
because you can almost feel it in the
air when when it's coming you know you
can feel that they've lost that phrase
lost the dressing room I've always
wondered if that was true
because it's a real thing yeah I think
so I mean I I probably felt that when
Roy Hodgson was there I don't think many
players were enjoying the training or
having them and I was almost felt like I
was trying to like come on you you know
is there private comments though between
you and Gerard where you go uh this is
not oh yeah of course listen we're not
we're like fans if that would be maybe
I'll tell her what are you doing here
why has he done that uh I I always
remember and the only time I've ever did
that did this in my whole career
we lost a home to Blackpool under Royal
I think it was an international break
and I'd stop playing for England then
and I couldn't sleep
and I went in the next morning and I
went straight into his office
and he was actually having a coach's
meeting
and I was probably
33 34 so I was a really experienced Pro
and we just had this big discussion with
all the cultures and it wasn't
and probably said things soon that
happened maybe you know he was talking
about what he wanted to do for that and
everything you can do that you can't do
it wasn't me questioning him as a
manager it was almost like I want to
help him and not because he again he
needed help as a manager he needed help
as a Liverpool manager as such
and
it was almost like no if you if if you
come out and say that or if you play
this play everyone's just going to you
you can't do that anymore that's got to
stop I wouldn't name the names I was
talking about I wouldn't do that but
that wasn't a case of me saying you
don't know what you're doing you needed
it wasn't an arrogant way
it was in a way as if like again the
club was just like oh my God where are
we going what are we doing it wasn't for
sort of it was more trying to help the
situation
reading trying to help him as a as a
managers I knew it was tough
sounds like he's lost a dressing room at
that point oh yeah yeah yeah no I said
that you know a lot of the play is what
I'm saying is he hadn't lost me as such
as I said no no manager could lose me or
get me in some ways and that I always
felt like I wasn't really playing for
them I mean I was behind every manager
and wanted to take things from every
manager we hear these stories where
they're like the the CEO has had a
conversation with a player that's a
disgrace is that is that is that true
have you ever heard of that happening
where the CEO of the club will have a
conversation with the player about the
manager is the manager right do we need
to move him on what's going on in the
dressing room because if I was to CEO of
a club
and I wasn't like I'm seeing on the
pitch that the club is performing badly
I might go and post TV aside or you
aside and go how's everything going that
happened once to me and I just
absolutely completely said this is an
absolute joke
that happened in 2007.
with American owners
Hicks and Gillette oh gosh that was a
yeah they'd had a big follow-up with
Rafa Benitez over transfer attacks
whatever it must have been and they
wanted to sacrifer and bring Jag and
cleanseman
and they
me and Steve had the same agent
and rather it wasn't a case of we'd
speak to them on the phone I never
really ever you know never spoke to no
need to
they said
would Stevie and kind of be okay if Rafa
Benitez was changed and we brought young
klinsman in
and I was like what we've been in the
Champions League final about two months
before so we've been in underneath we've
been in two Champions League finals in
three years
but listen I'm not defending the
Americans in anybody but I know Rapha
but he says as a manager there's
hardware for a CEO and an owner I know
that he pushes them to the absolute
limit where I think in the end they
think oh he's you know the performance
high maintenance type of thing it is
like that as a manager
but it was like what
absolutely not I mean why are you even
speak no it's
I couldn't believe the question was even
asked number one because of how well
we've done as a team but also number two
why are you asking me it's just like no
don't ever almost put me in that
position or situation or you can fire
the manager yeah but if that did happen
at that time you can imagine it happen
at other clubs certainly Chelsea who was
just a revolving door and Rafa was
eventually fired by them wasn't he I
believe
yeah but like three years later or
something like that that was like that
was when it was at its best it wasn't a
football and decision like that was a
personal decision so you so you
I'm guessing you didn't go and tell Rafa
that conversation had happened no okay
eventually you retire and interestingly
which kind of Buck's the trend again you
you said you were
happy that your career was done um why
the roller coaster of emotions
it was yeah I just I had enough of it
you know behind the highs and lows
and the high was never as
high as the low was low
if you like
so now I was done I didn't it's very
difficult to leave Liverpool
I'd seen other plays Lee because in
Liverpool fans eyes I'm rightly so ways
better than Liverpool I actually said
that an interview once who's bigger than
Liverpool
but we've had plays with left and gone
to Real Madrid didn't last longer but as
a local player you could never move to
another English Club
or certainly feel like you were going on
the up
you may be your career might be petering
out and you go lower down Liverpool fans
would be fine with that but a local
player moving
very difficult there's you look at the
reaction to Mike alone moving to Real
Madrid and then subsequently ends up at
Manchester United even Steve McManaman
is not loved as much as he should be for
how good a play he was at Liverpool I
feel because he left on a bus when I
went to Real Madrid didn't go to a big
rival he went to the biggest club in the
world
that was always in my head
not that I could
necessarily move to
a European giant but the thing of
how do you get out
how do we tell how do I time this right
I don't want to carry on playing when
I'm embarrassing myself and embarrassing
the club or the supporters so I've
almost got the timings out and I know
towards the end of my career there was
Liverpool fans really questioning
why I got a new contract at a certain
stage you know why I was playing and
saying games ahead of another player not
not massively not where people outside
of Liverpool would know but
again you smell it you feel it the local
paper fans you know it just you know
you're not stupid and I had that to
start to be clear the flip side of that
way
it was always that thing of am I fully
rated am I good enough to play for
Liverpool so I always had that
through my career and
I think the one thing that's helped me
in my career is
I've always had the feeling that I'm not
fully rated
or I think I've been underestimated a
little bit as a player and maybe in the
role that I do now where
no one's expected what I've ended up
doing so it's almost maybe that takes a
little bit of pressure off but I've
always felt like
I've got something to prove they don't
quite think I'm good enough I wasn't
sure I wasn't Stephen I wasn't Michael I
wasn't Robbie Fowler when I got into the
team I was a slow being and I got better
and better and better as the years went
on through experience and maturity
but absorbs that thing of
am I good enough did that make you work
harder than people around you
yeah yeah
I I yeah 100 it always felt like um
always I have it now where I always feel
like
there's some fight of some battle to win
or something like
you know and I never look back I never
sort of think I've done that
I I always remember something Brendan
Rodgers said to me
you just become Liverpool manager and
he'd been promoted the year before with
Swansea
and he told me about Alex Ferguson sent
him a letter as I think Alex Vegas must
maybe do two every manager gets promoted
and he's written this letter well done
congratulations and he said to Brandon
Rogers something
he said
but remember never lose your fear
and I remember Brendan Rodgers telling
me and it was like a light bulb moment
and I went I've never lost mine
it almost like yeah
I'm not trying to compare myself to
Doug's face what I'm saying is when he
said that was like a piece of advice to
Brendan Rogers and I'm sure he said it
to all the managers and players
but it was like probably the biggest
figure in English football at that time
and I didn't say nothing to Brenda wow
that is so important to success I think
always having that fear
without letting it sort of overtake you
where you can't actually you know
mentally you can't achieve what you want
to do but always have that thing where
you think someone's going to take me
Place someone's looking to beat me so
who am I competing with you know always
having that and I've I've still got that
today I've also got the fear that
use the next plunder coming
um you know what
what angle are they going to come out
I'll think about what I'm going to say
before I get to a game it's the opposite
of complacency right that's yeah yeah
and whether you can put that into people
I've never had complacency in my life I
don't think I ever will
do you think yeah it's a good point do
you think you can teach that or is that
just a
yeah because I don't even we do you ever
do you ever feel I mean obviously you're
very successful
do you ever feel like you've done enough
um of course not I I don't yeah of
course not
do you think that's that's a that is a
treat with with people you know you
bring on the podcast as well it's just I
I mean even when I'm speaking to you a
lot of time I'm speaking about poor
games I'm not speaking about great games
and it just that constant feeling as if
I can do more I should have done more
but I'm the thing I'm most curious about
is of course I see that in on all my
guess I mean Eddie Hearn comes to mind
his book is called Relentless and he's
you know I remember I remember him
asking him like what's the end game and
he's like well you know one day we'll
we'll sell this company okay so that day
you sell the company then you go to the
beach and have the pina coladas and you
could just sit in his face for horror
the thought that even if he sold
matching boxing he he would need to go
and just carry on fighting for something
and we all have that we all I think we
have it hardwired into us as just
generally as humans and this is why
we're here in these buildings and have
this the roads and the cars that our
ancestors put something in us where they
said you're gonna struggle forward but
then I think other some people have it
to an even more obsessive degree and
it's usually people who've had some
early experience where
losing
um
came at a real cost to their self-esteem
or to someone around them that mattered
or their dad or you know they just
learned early that losing meant that
they were they weren't enough they
weren't Worthy
and that's kind of what I was trying to
understand in you is
because that I see that particularly in
your story that like obsessive
competitiveness but I don't see it in
everybody
so where did that like what was the cost
of losing or not winning or not you know
I've said it before I go back to me
a child with football a feeling of
winning losing you were playing since
you were three or something right yeah
playing really early and
I was thinking about you know I was
thinking about what I'm going to say
when I come on here what am I going to
say that's you know
different than you know you have lots of
guests and even that's you know
everything like yeah just just thinking
you know well nice point would you like
to be I don't know what you want to ask
me
but
I think that the role I'm in now
we talk about the
you know I've read that book bounce have
you read that book no the table Yeah the
ten thousand hours sort of mindset of
you know that and
you know I was a footballer for
professional football for 17 years but
you don't realize when you're in it will
be forwarded that it's actually a small
penalty of your life really
and the job I'm in now I'm probably
going to be doing that a lot more than
I'm actually a professional footballer
and
I actually think my 10 000 hours
of what I did as a kid is almost not
just to be a footballer so actually be
a Ponder an analyst whatever you want to
call it
because I don't think anybody I want to
talk I'm the reason I'm talking about
this is because I'm talking about being
competitive now as a
pundit talking on TV making good points
analyzing games is that who's going to
come next who's going to try and take my
place but I I don't think
many if any
I've had my
education in football the way I have I
don't think anyone could have done more
in football
than what I did to prepare me to get to
where I was when I finished what about
Gary
no do you think Gary do you say no what
a meat what I mean by this is not in
terms of like
putting hard work and I'm thinking talk
about I was getting taken to football
games from the age of four or five
amateur football
I was in the back of the van with all
the players so listen to men talk
football
straight when you come back go back to
the pub everyone back the pub so we'd
meet at the pub
12 on a Saturday and a Sunday my dad was
the manager we're all back at the van
I'm listening to these I'm five six
listen to men talk football back to the
pub I'm playing on the pool table all
the football results are coming in but
again that constant talk of football why
don't you become a manager people would
think you'd become your leader yeah I
actually think Leeds is interesting in
that I think it's almost like a
different type of leadership now I think
in the 70s 80s maybe 90s
we always cast a leader as me
you know whether he had the captain's
arm on your screaming shout out to
referee your own players you're aging
people on and that is leadership
but I don't think that that person
necessarily ends up always being the
manager I'm just thinking of Michael
arteta I played against him I don't
think he had him say a word on the pitch
and then you could say someone like a
Tony Adams well has he not Arsenal
manager you know he's that leadership
well he's had a little goal with the
management more than a little goal but I
think management now is set up for more
of the studious types not that I don't
think about the game but
I actually think I've made a great
decision not to be a manager because
I think when I was playing I thought
like a manager and I think
what managers put themselves through is
probably what I put myself through as a
player where you really torture yourself
and you get that emotionally involved
and
I I would back my football knowledge I I
wouldn't be embarrassed if you're in
trouble Peg Guardiola came on Monday
Night Football and we were talking to
football and I might disagree with
something he said he might disagree with
I wouldn't feel out of place
but would I make a good football manager
I don't think so I spoke to Michael
Holman's and sometimes it's when someone
else says something to you it really
hits home and he
I was interviewing him but he said to me
you're not a people person and I was
like what aren't I even not really said
you don't have a
you know you don't suffer feel you know
you're quite sharper people at times
and it was only I thought well yeah he'd
probably raised and that wouldn't help
you be a
top football managers you've got to put
up with things and basically
you know if if a player came into me and
said he was injured my first thought was
he's telling a lie
I'm like that with my kids if they say
the sick
you know I just I can't get that feeling
up we had that
no the bluffing you know that type of
I'd always think I'd be questioning you
know players speaking of your kids how
did fatherhood change you
because I heard you say it changed you
and I couldn't didn't find the details
so how did it change you
well I don't think it changed when my
wife is pregnant I don't think I
realized the enormously of having a kid
or having me some I should say
I wasn't there for the bath
I was Liverpool had a game
in Europe on the Tuesday in the
Champions League and I was with my wife
on the Sunday she went in but obviously
I didn't deal with the baby by the Mundy
and we were traveling I had to go but I
say I had to I didn't have to go
but it was always that I think at the
time it was like oh it should be okay
you know my mom was there and I went
and there we're gonna be three and after
half an hour I was like uh but we we
sung up was born the day before the game
we played the game in Europe and I
always remember we got we drew three
three and we went off to Champions
League which was a big a big blow and I
always remember Jared Julia after the
game toasten me
and I always loved and admired him for
that because I used to think
I can't believe he's done that because
I think I'd feel like my stomach's being
ripped out if we're just gonna have the
champions league as a manager in some
ways and it was I I didn't I didn't
realize how big it was to to have a
child uh I think
yeah they do not just for being there
when James was born more for being there
you know you know he's going through you
know it's not easy
uh you know the birth of a child so
yeah I regret that
I would advise anyone in my situation to
you know be there but I think I think it
is the common thing now I think even
when you see
you know different example but sort of
regime still at the world cup goes home
on the back of his house getting baggled
whereas maybe years ago that'd be seen
as if like well yeah yeah you'd have to
wear a cup yeah you're playing for
England you know and I think there's a
lot more
probably get empathy and understanding
from football managers now to sort of
you know family matters but with me with
me kids it's like I wouldn't say I was a
kid person before I had kids you know
with relatives or something
but I feel like I'm completely different
now so I've got nieces and nephews who
it's funny really because
man and Nicholas kids are but we're all
they're older so James is 20 me as 18 me
lives in New York now
but we've got nieces and nephews and
we're almost at times in the house on
our own it's like should we go and see
the kids we see the kids not even our
kids it's a bit like we need a fix of
kids for sort of an hour you know we're
handing them up have you got a boyfriend
have you got a girlfriend you know all
this thing that you did when your kids
were growing up because we we really
miss and
I think my wife would have wanted more
kids but I was no we've got two we've
got the boy and a girl Nicola your
childhood sweetheart
um you married her in 2005 I believe
yeah yeah yeah you've forgotten yeah
Champions League yeah
one of the quotes that um struck me was
this so did you speak to her no no no
because you know why because she tells
me everything really she can't keep a
secret she would tell me everything I
reckon I could have got it I will find
out maybe in the future party
um this quote here where it says
this part of my life story is the one I
find most difficult to tell I could talk
to you for hours expressing my fondness
for certain players or football teams
but doing the same thing about the woman
you love question mark hmm
yeah I do find that even with shorter me
Mom or Dad
really you know saying you love them and
I do to my wife of course I do but
there's there's definitely when we have
disagreements
my wife I'll you know it'll be I'm not
saying too much
but you say but when you're on the phone
talking to sky or you're doing your
newspaper column you can't shut up you
know about football and ideas where's
this you know I I want that and
I'm just not I just I do find it
difficult I'm just not that patient to
come out with those
words and
I do find I don't know if it's
I don't know what it is I mean I think
the brothers are the same
we were yeah you know we're not like a
an overly Huggy kissy family I'm like
that with my kids and I'm like that with
my wife but I wouldn't say I wouldn't be
classed to someone whoever does it now
which she can't see as an affectionate
person or a romantic person
I wouldn't say romantic I might say
affectionate is that different I don't
know affectionate I think of like
kissing and schmoozing romantic I think
of like gestures you know like the roses
and stuff like that oh probably more
yeah yeah I would do things like that
maybe yeah yeah
as you look back on the role that your
parents played in your life what would
you
um I've got all of these wonderful
photos here which I printed off earlier
on oh cool
show me
I'll slide the photos to you and you
tell me you tell me what the person
means in your life then what about that
one
oh that's me Dad yeah yeah huge
influence yeah still like
a huge influence now
a larger than life character I think
these past I wouldn't well this I know
I'm a strong character no I'm a big
character and I think that comes from
from me Dad uh I think
that personality and character he's
passed on to me
I think is the reason why
become the player I have because
the reason I got there was not
justability
I don't think my ability is Champions
League final level
but I think my personality and character
is and that's what dragged
you know Jamie had a footballer to a
Champions League final because I can
and mentally strong and tough and you
know it
you know what and you have ups and downs
in your life in your career but as I
said not getting your way not in
stopping you no obstacles in the way and
I think a lot of that comes from me Dad
what about this one
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
what does this mean to you
yeah
that's me life
yeah that's
me Nick London's two kids in Ibiza
uh yeah I'm really proud of my family
and what we we all have and listen we
said before no one's got no one's
amazing no one's got
you know he's got all the answers we
have ups and downs like any family or
you know you have words
at the moment me as in New York now we
haven't got we're the same as any other
family
can't sleep is she okay my wife's going
to sleep probably three or four o'clock
in the morning because of the time
difference making sure she's in and you
know just that whole balance of life she
she was only supposed to do three months
she then told us a week ago she wants to
do a year
and we're excited to bring her own but
so proud of her to go to New York at 18.
living on at all you know but it's it's
it's tough but again so proud and James
what he's doing playing football I mean
uh not easy I know being a son of a
footballer a girl but I always say again
don't use that as an excuse because
there's positives to that as well you
know uh but no really really you know
we're proud of them and what I always
say
to them is
have a story
when you get to my age older make sure
you've got a story so
you know what have you done do amazing
things that me has gone to New York I
don't know whether that's going to lead
but what a thing to tell your own kids I
lived in New York for a year you know
and that's I always drawn that into the
kids
you know he wants to do special things
amazing things
just go on Smash life basically just go
and do it Jamie thank you thank you so
much and we have a closing tradition on
this planet no I haven't got a question
you can you can you can take your time
on that part okay the part and also when
I ask people this this question they
usually take like
five minutes to think about the answer
which is funny but um the question
that's been left for you obviously the
person didn't know they were leaving it
for you is
interesting you
do uncomfortable situations bring the
best or worst out of you
I would say the best
I think
whether that's
on the pitch off the pitch family stuff
I think when when
in the moment I think I can
almost narrow it down and not get too
hysterical or two it's a bit like okay
need to do that that and that
and almost
be a little bit calmer in there and that
comes maybe as well
on the pitch when
if you know you've had a bad injury or
you feel like someone's going to take
your place or you feel like something's
a bit like
almost was a car compartmentalizes it is
that the right word yeah uh not always
good with words
but no just get that
focus of like that's what I need to do
and I think that's I think it's it's
probably a strength of mine of like not
worrying about its face I think I like
doing that with the kids
or my wife if they come to me with a
problem
and it's always easier someone else's
problems because you don't have as much
the emotional attachment and to think
about a few other things but it's a bit
like
and that's what I love about being a dad
helping your own kids with those
problems and being I've been there
before and
sort of given that advice the best thing
about getting older I think is
experience and being able to give that
to someone
and I think a lot of the time you know
it's funny with me son
in that I think when he's in a really
good mood and he's happy and his life's
going really well
I know he's out with his mates and he
doesn't need but
I know sometimes if he's
not feeling 100 I can just feel it I can
smell it
and it'll come to me and you know you
you want to be there to help you know
that sort of passion on something so I
think from an individual point of view
yes but I also love the fact that
I love helping people on that side of it
when because we're all we're all in
uncomfortable situations at different
times and whenever life's going great
I'm obviously in something around the
corner
slightly terrifying because it's so true
Jamie thank you so much thank you thank
you for having the conversation I really
I was so excited to talk to you because
of the mentality you have and how how
that's resulted in such tremendous
career says for for Liverpool but now
also as a pundit and I can see that kind
of Relentless fight in you and how that
hasn't disappeared and I find it so
incredibly inspiring that mentality is
at the very heart of your success
because I do believe to some degree that
that is something that people can pick
up like Talent is one thing being seven
foot tall and becoming a basketball
player but knowing that there is this
other thing which is the the values we
hold in our mind and the behaviors that
creates that we can all embody which you
perfectly embody I mean Peter Crouch
really I think I told you after the
reason I reached out to you is because
of that conversation with Peter Crouch
and I just thought God like the way he
talks about you like you're on this
other level of
extreme you know winning mentality
um is tremendously inspiring but also
there's a cost to that and you've kind
of detailed the cost you went to is it
Billy the psychologist you went to Bill
Bill yeah Bill Bestway can you kind of
detailed the cost of it is this still on
though yeah yeah Oh I thought we'd
finished no no I'm just wrapping up
but yeah that's exactly it it's um it's
the cost of that mentality which I think
is also important to be clear on um so
thank you for being so honest really
appreciate it thank you for being here
thank you
inside now one of our sponsors on this
podcast and I'm here to tell you about
their vpro platform security and data
protection are totally non-negotiable
when it comes to the technology I use
for my businesses I'm constantly
thinking about where we can upgrade our
systems to protect against potential
threats so this is where Intel V pro has
become our go-to Intel V Pro is built
for businesses it has a hardware-based
multi-layer platform security features
protecting from cyber attacks threat
detection and also recovery systems all
in one platform in an Ever challenging
cyber landscape if I can put measures in
place that I believe will save me time
and money then I absolutely will so head
over to
intel.co.ukvpro to find out how it could
work for your business
[Music]
thank you